vous avez sans doute beaucoup entendu
parler du taux de reproduction effectif
quarté en tout cas c'était le sujet de
la première vidéo de cette série pour
rappel rt le nombre moyen d'individus
qu'une personne infectée à l'instant t
contamine et de façon critique si rt est
supérieur à 1
alors la pandémie reprendra de plus
belle avec une croissance exponentielle
dévastatrice on a ainsi vu que le grand
défi de cette crise était de garder rt
en dessous de 1 tout en permettant une
restitution des libertés pour cela il
est critique de disposer de bien
meilleures données pour suivre en temps
réel et de manière fiable
l'évolution de rt par exemple grâce au
test groupe et au suivi des égouts aux
applications de notification à
l'exposition et de préférer les
interventions capable de réduire
drastiquement rt comme les gestes
barrière l'hygiène la distanciation
physique le fait de rester chez soi
autant que possible le port de masques
l'interdiction de large rassemblement et
la mise en quarantaine en cas de risque
important de kobe 19
cependant il ya un aspect important du
rt qu'on n'a pas beaucoup mentionné
jusque là à savoir les variations
individuelles de contamination or des
études récentes suggèrent une énorme
variabilité dans les taux de
contamination individuel ainsi 80% des
contaminations pourraient naître du
caddie pour cent des individus infectés
à en croire ces chiffres alors que
beaucoup ne contaminerait presque
personne
certains semble contaminer un grand
nombre d'autres personnes
on parle parfois de super propagateur ou
de super contaminateur pour l'instant
ces grandes variations sur ses taux de
variation sont sans doute encore à
prendre avec des pincettes
néanmoins il est intéressant et
probablement utile d'envisager les
conséquences d'une très grande
variabilité des taux de reproduction
individuelles notamment car certaines
interventions seraient alors
particulièrement efficace dans ce cas
finalement relativement probable
le risque dessus
sion en urgence l'identification et la
suppression des situations où ce risque
est particulièrement important comme
l'expliquent jamie lloyd smith de
l'université de californie à los angeles
si vous pouvez prédire les circonstances
qui donnent lieu à ces événements les
maths montre que vous pouvez très très
rapidement limité la capacité de la
maladie à se propager à ce sujet
plusieurs études suggèrent que les
espaces clos sont particulièrement
propices à la super contamination ainsi
sur 318 kloster identifiés en chine un
seul semble avoir lieu à l'extérieur
autrement dit il semble que l'intérieur
des bars et des restaurants est bien
plus dangereux que les terrasses ou les
parcs
ainsi si vous voulez vraiment aller
consommer dans ces dieux il semble
largement préférable de demander à être
installés en terrasse même si bien sûr
même à l'extérieur
le danger de contamination peut rester
très important notre étude faite au
japon va dans le même sens et suggère
que les risques d'infection pourrait
être dix neuf fois supérieur à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
ce chiffre exact est à prendre avec de
grosses pincettes néanmoins ils
suggèrent une prévalence importante des
contaminations à l'intérieur quoi qu'il
en soit il semble que le japon a fait de
cette observation un élément central de
sa stratégie contre locaux vides et ce
avec un relatif succès en tout cas si on
compare le nombre de décès officiel du
coc vide au japon versus les nombre de
décès en europe même si bon il faut bien
sûr ne pas réduire la stratégie du japon
à cette seule mesure
et même si des doutes ont été émis quant
à la validité des chiffres des autorités
s'ils reconnaissent cet autre étude
corrobore elle aussi l'hypothèse d' une
surcontamination dans les espaces clos
en étudiant cette fois le cas de
l'europe même si les données sont encore
une fois très parcellaires et pleines de
billets ceci soulève l'importance d'une
bonne ventilation de ces espaces et
peut-être d'ouvrir régulièrement les
fenêtres pour aérer l'explication
biophysique probable de l'effet prononcé
des espaces clos sur la surcontamination
pourrait venir de la capacité du virus à
se propager via des gouttelettes expulsé
par exemple lorsqu'on parle à voix haute
et qui flotte dans l'air cette étude de
2010 9 montre en effet que ceux qui
parlent plus fort et mettre davantage de
telles particules en particulier ceci
suggère que les lieux clos plein de
chance de cris ou d'effort physique
intense pourrait être particulièrement
propice à une surcontamination ainsi
annulé les groupes de chorales les
places de zumba les concerts et fermé
les boîtes de nuit
peut-être aussi les stades de football
ça semble être une façon efficace de
réduire drastiquement les risques de
seconde vague
la propagation des maladies à forte
variabilité individuelle de contagiosité
a été formalisée en 2005 dans un article
séminal publiée dans nature avec un
modèle d'une étonnante simplicité à la
fois conceptuelle et mathématiques
l'idée fondamentale est la suivante
chaque individu a un taux de
reproduction air individuel différents
la moyenne des airs individuelle est
égal au taux de reproduction moyens rt
cependant le r individuelle d'un
individu donné peut être plus ou moins
éloignés du rt l'écart typique entre est
individuelle et rt et quantifié par un
paramètre qu'à appeler paramètres de
dispersion en fait de manière plus
précise
on suppose que le r individuel suis une
distribution appelé loi gamma dont les
paramètres sont alpha est égal à cas et
bêta est égal à kddi visé par air ou air
est ici le r moyen théorique pour
comprendre cette loi je vous invite à
aller sur cette page des choses que j'ai
créée pour jouer avec ce paramètre cas
et voir comment ils influencent la
distribution des aides individuelles
ainsi qu'à et très grand proche de
l'infini alors tout le monde aura le
même air individuel égal à rt et il n'y
aura pas de variations individuelles
al'inverse plus qu'à est faible plus on
s'éloigne d'une courbe en cloche
lorsque cas est égal à 1 la cloche
disparaît on obtient alors une des
croissances exponentielles dr individuel
avec cas l 1 les faibles valeurs de r
individuelles sont plus probables tandis
que les grandes valeurs dr individuel
deviennent exponentiellement improbable
si bien qu'un individu a très peu de
chances d'avoir un air individuel égale
à deux ou trois fois
le r moyen théorique autrement dit qu'en
cas est égal à 1
il y a beaucoup de variabilité mais les
cas extrêmes restent exponentiellement
rares cependant quand air descend en
dessous de 1 variabilité devient alors
extrêmement la plupart des individus ont
alors un air individuel quasi nulle
tandis que des cas où le individuels et
trois fois le r moyen théorique
deviennent probable ainsi pour k est
égale 10.5 lui pour cent des individus
ont alors est individuelle supérieure à
3 fois le r moyen théorique tandis que
1% des individus auront un air
individuelle supérieure à 6 fois le r
moyen théorique pour ar moyen théorique
égal 3 ça voudrait dire que 1% des
infectés contamineront en moyenne
- dix-huit personnes on parle alors de
queues de distribution épaisse et ses
grandes que sont très surprenantes
en fait on peut calculer les
probabilités d nombre de contaminations
par un individu donné sa chambre
individuelle d'un individu en supposant
que chaque rencontre de l'individu aura
une petite probabilité de contamination
et que le nombre de rencontres de
l'individu est grand dans ce cas on
s'attend à ce que le nombre de
contaminations par l'individu sa chanson
r individuel suivent une loi dite de
poissons poisson comme l'animal mais
avec une majuscule car ça renvoie en
fait aux mathématiciens signons denis
poisson le mec qui a rejeté le manuscrit
séminal d'evariste galois car il n'avait
pas réussi à le comprendre
ok désolé je précise à se ressembler
j'ai un peu un complexe de jalousie
envers poisson depuis que j'ai vu sur
wikipédia que la place le considéré
presque comme son fils qui pastel
bref je ne vais pas vous ennuyer avec
les détails de la loi de poisson
toujours est il que si on suppose que
sachant le r individuelles le nombre de
contaminations suédois de poissons alors
le nombre de contaminations a priori
avant de connaître les erreurs
individuelles
suit une loi dite binomiale négative je
sais ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
nouveaux concepts d'un coup ce qu'il
faut retenir de tout ça c'est que ça
fait surtout des équations relativement
simple et en utilisant un logiciel comme
desnos on peut facilement estimer les
probabilités de cas extrêmes en fonction
de la valeur de cas et le constat est le
même que pour la loi gamma plus qu'à est
petit plus on observe une distribution
étonnamment est allé et plus la
probabilité de super contaminateur
devient alors importante
alors avoir des jolis modèles
mathématiques c'est bien mais pour qu'il
devienne utile il est critique de se
demander s'il est possible d'estimer
adéquatement les paramètres de ses
modèles avec des données empiriques
or malheureusement a priori si rt peut
être estimée en suivant l'augmentation
du nombre de cas d'hospitalisation et de
décès mais aussi via des statistiques et
d'appels d'urgence et l'analyse pcr des
eaux usées il semble malheureusement
bien moins évident d'estimer le
paramètre de dispersion car dans les
articles que j'ai épluché en tout cas il
semble y avoir trois principales
méthodes pour estimer ce paramètre à
partir de données empiriques la première
et la plus fiable concerne le cas où
l'on dispose des données sur le réseau
de contamination crasse typiquement des
efforts de contact racing manuel c'est
typiquement ce qui a réussi à obtenir la
corée du sud
en déployant des moyens importants très
tôt dans la pandémie pour retracer les
contaminations en utilisant toutes
sortes de données pour mieux comprendre
qui a contaminé qui ceci dit
malheureusement j'étais pas trouvé
d'article qui a analysé ces données pour
estimer le paramètre de dispersion car
si vous en connaissez ça m'intéresse
malheureusement le détail de ces données
est souvent absent des données
collectées par des contacts racing moins
rigoureux cependant on dispose alors
plus aisément de données sur la
proportion des infectés qui non
contaminé personnes il s'agit alors
d'ajuster le paramètre cas pour qu'il
explique au mieux cette proportion
d'individus infectés qui n'ont pas
propager le virus
avec de telles données l'article de 2005
estime qu'ebola à une relativement
faible variabilité individuelle du taux
de reproduction et plus précisément ils
ont estimé que le cas d'ebola était de
l'ordre de 5
autrement dit dans le cas d'ebola la
plupart des individus étaient contagieux
et on s'attend à ce que chacun contamine
de une à trois personnes
tu seras c'est la rougeole par contre on
ne variabilité importante avec cas de
l'ordre de 0,2 c'est à dire que beaucoup
de contamination sont dues a
relativement peu de personnes cependant
pour d'autres maladies même de telles
données ne sont pas ou peu disponible
dans le cas du coc vide en particulier
on dispose principalement de données
macroscopique sur la propagation de la
pandémie dans différentes sous régions
du monde mais en fait ça ça peut suffire
à voir d estimation grossière de la
valeur de cas en effet quand le nombre
d'infectés est faible quand on en
reparlera plus tard dans cette vidéo le
comportement de la pandémie avec de
faibles valeurs de cas
est très différent de celui où k est
important c'est en tout cas la proche
utilisée dans le cas du coc vide par ces
deux articles
le premier est toutefois très largement
un conclusif avec une estimation de cas
entre 0,01 et 10 le second toutefois
conclu avec un cas entre 0 et 0,5 et 0,2
autrement dit selon ce second article
qui s'appuie sur beaucoup plus de
données à valeur du paramètre de
dispersion le cas dans le cas du coc
vide est particulièrement faible ce qui
a des conséquences très contre intuitif
une valeur de cas autour d'eux
argument signifie qu'il y aurait une
énorme variabilité inter personnelles de
la contagiosité une fois infecté par le
cos vide une conséquence étonnante de
cela par exemple c'est que environ 70%
des individus infectés pourraient ne
contamine et personnes
al'inverse 10% des infectés
contaminerait au moins neuf personnes
tandis que 1% des infectés contaminerait
au moins 50 personnes
dès lors si cas est de l'ordre de 0,1
autour de 80 % des infections pourraient
être dues qu'à 10% des individus
infectés identifier ces super
contaminateur et les isoler permettrait
alors de réduire drastiquement la
propagation du coït 19
sans restreindre les libertés du plus
grand nombre ceci étant dit il est
important de souligner que les modèles
dépit des logiques on a considéré jusque
là ne sont que des descriptions
macroscopique de la contagiosité
effectives ces études s'appuie sur la
manière dont la pandémie se propage en
pratique par conséquent le r
individuelle ne devrait pas être
interprété comme une propriété d'un
individu en fait le r individuelle est
davantage le résultat des propriétés
biologiques de l'individu mais aussi et
peut-être surtout de ses comportements
et des contacts que cet individu aura un
individu qui prêtent très attention aux
gestes barrière se laver les mains à
rester chez soi autant que possible la
distanciation physique au port de masque
à éviter les foules et à restreindre ses
fréquentations social aura un air
individuelles plus faibles comme rt le r
individuel n'est pas une fatalité
vous pouvez agir sur votre air
individuel pour réduire les risques de
seconde vague en particulier dans
l'hypothèse où k est effectivement aussi
faible les événements de super
contamination aurait une importance
disproportionnée
dès lors l'interdiction des grands
rassemblements pourraient être une
manière particulièrement efficace de
réduire drastiquement le taux de
reproduction effective silca est
effectivement faible comme ça semble
être le cas il semble justifier que vous
voyez des petits groupes d'amis
cependant il semble qu'il faille
vraiment éviter d'organiser des soirées
avec 10 personnes ou plus en ces temps
ci malheureusement plus on est de fous
plus on risque la super contamination en
particulier en supposant que la fenêtre
de contagiosité dure entre quatre jours
et une semaine il pourrait être efficace
pour chacun d'entre nous de prendre soin
de ne jamais interagir avec plus de 10 p
différentes et idéalement peut-être
jamais avec plus de cinq personnes
pendant de telles intervalle de temps en
effet les calculs mathématiques suggère
que si on limite tout le monde à 5
interactions pendant cette fenêtre de
contagiosité et sica est égal à 0,1
alors ceci pourrait suffire à diviser rt
par deux voire par trois et ainsi
garantir perte est inférieure à 1 à
cause d'une faible valeur de cas réduire
le nombre de personnes avec qui on
interagit au cours de la semaine
pourrait alors être une intervention
particulièrement efficace ceci étant dit
si on suppose que cas est effectivement
aussi faible et sachant à quel point le
coc vide avec ses différents individus
de manière très différente
il semble probable qu'il y ait de forte
variabilité de contagiosité au niveau
biologique aussi malheureusement pour
l'instant on ne comprend absolument pas
ce qui fait qu'un individu sera plus
contagieux qu'un autre tout comme il est
encore très difficile de prédire si
l'état physique et d'un individu déjà
infecté se dégradera fortement dans la
semaine à venir voire parfois même dans
les heures à venir
davantage de recherches semblent
indispensables pour mieux comprendre
cette maladie et proposer des solutions
bien plus ciblées pour la contenir qu'un
confinement globale et brutale
néanmoins la recherche avance selon
cette étude en particulier il semble
qu'il pourrait y avoir une influence de
la charge virale au moment de
l'infection
un individu exposés à beaucoup de virus
sarr skov de d'un coup pourrait
peut-être avoir une réaction biologique
qui le rendrait ensuite plus contagieux
si tel est le cas et qu'il faut encore
absolument confirmer avec davantage de
recherches
il pourrait alors être important de
tenir compte des chaînes de super
contaminateur pour isoler encore un peu
plus ces individus sans même aller
jusqu'à ce suivi de super contaminateur
il semble important d'exploiter
l'existence de super contaminateur dans
la recherche les individus contagieux en
particulier identifier l'individu qui a
contaminé une personne infectée pourrait
être critique car sachant que cet
individu a infecté une personne surtout
sica est très faible
il deviendra alors beaucoup plus
probable que cet individu infecté
plusieurs autres personnes
et si jamais on découvre que l'individu
a infecté au moins deux personnes
alors il serait judicieux d'effectuer un
contact racing manuel exhaustif de cet
individu
en effet sachant qu'un individu a
infecté au moins deux personnes
la probabilité qu'il soit un super
contaminateur devient alors très élevé
on peut voir ceci est graphiquement
comparant le caca égale 1 1 okaka égale
0,1 dans le caca égal 1 qui correspond à
une loi dite géométriques canton zone
sera parti où le nombre d'infectés est
supérieure à 2 la courbe ne perd pas sa
forme
si on résume sur la partie où le nombre
d'infectés est supérieure à 10 la courbe
garde encore une fois la même forme
cependant qu'en cas est égal à 0,1 des
consignes sur la partie où le nombre
d'infectés est supérieure à 2 alors la
courbe devient tout à coup beaucoup
beaucoup plus étalés si on zoome sur la
partie où ce nombre d'infectés est
supérieure à 10 alors les cas de super
contamination deviennent tout à coup
assez probable ceci illustre bien le
fait que sachant qu'un infectées a
contaminé quelques personnes alors il
devient probable qu'il en est en fait
infecté beaucoup plus généralement cette
hétérogénéité de la contagiosité a des
conséquences très étrange qui ont à voir
avec l'étrange théorème qui affirme que
en moyenne
vous avez moins d'amis que vos amis et
d'ailleurs d'autres propriétés des gras
sauce aux interactions physiques suggère
que ceci réduit le seuil nécessaire pour
atteindre une immunité de groupe
effective
même si ce serait reste probablement
autour de dix fois supérieur à
l'immunité acquise jusque là et je pas
sûr qu'on veut faire dit confinement
ceci étant dit que la raison soit
biologique ou comportementales les tout
aussi crucial de ne pas stigmatiser ces
super contaminateur c'est super
contaminateur sont plus encore des
victimes du coc vide
non seulement ces victimes ont elles
subi la maladie mais elle pourra aussi
devoir vivre avec le traumatisme d'avoir
propagé cette maladie et avoir ainsi a
été indirectement responsable de
dizaines et peut-être parfois de
centaines de nouveaux cas en fait
prendre conscience que chacun d'entre
nous pourrait être un tel super
contaminateur au moins en puissance
prendre des mesures pour réduire le
risque d'être soi même un super
contaminateur et défendre tous super
contaminateur d'un risque de
stigmatisation
ça semble être très désirable en ces
temps difficiles
une conséquence intérêts
une grande variabilité du taux de
contamination dont les effets ont
d'ailleurs été utilisée pour estimer cas
c'est le fait qu'un petit foyer de
qu'ovide a en fait de bonnes chances de
disparaître
en effet malgré rté important la
probabilité d'extinction d'une maladie à
très faible qu'à est initialement forte
oui parce que la plupart d'entre nous ne
sommes pas des supers contaminateur voir
la plupart d'entre nous de contamines
personnes mais alors ça voudrait dire
que pendant longtemps la pandémie peut
paraître sous contrôle dans une région
donnée mais tout à coup dès qu'un
individu est infecté et super contagieux
la maladie peut tout à coup explosé et
adopter la croissance exponentielle dont
on a tant parlé
autrement dit qu'en cas est très faible
il faut rester très vigilant même
lorsque tout semble sous contrôle
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire et
l'explication mathématiques de tout cela
est très élégante
bon alors on se rapproche de la fin de
cette vidéo et c'est le moment où je
vais me faire un peu plaisir et faire un
peu de maths ça me manque
mais bon si vous ne voulez pas jouir de
ses maths je ne vous en voudrez pas si
vous souhaitez directement à la
conclusion le modèle le plus simple et
le plus naturel est sans doute celui du
processus de galton watson où chaque
individu a une probabilité de nombre de
contaminations indépendante de tout ce
qui se passe ailleurs et qu'ils entrent
qu'à obéir à la loi binomiale négative
imaginons qu'on ait un seul individu
infecté pour commencer ainsi le nombre
z1 d'infecter après une étape de
contamination et le nombre x 1 de
personnes contaminées par un individu
infecté on a donc z1 est égal à 6 ans
puis en supposant qu'on a à z a infecté
à la première étape à la seconde
le nombre d'infectés z2 sera la somme
des nombres xj de contamination par les
individus j de la première étape qui
sont au nombre de sept ans
ainsi 7,2 et la somme projets allant de
1 à z 1 2 x 2 j plus généralement z n +
1 sera la somme pour j allant de a à z
ndx angie où chaque x angie est une
variable indépendante est identiquement
distribués selon ici la loi négative
binomiale tel est le processus de calton
watson une question qu'il est
intéressant de se poser et de maintenant
la suivante quelle est la probabilité
que la chaîne de contamination causée
par un individu finisse par s'éteindre
appelons qu elle la probabilité que
cette chaîne s'éteignent avants henn
itération pour qu'il y ait extinction 1
itération il faut soit qu'il y ait
extinction dès la première itération
soit que toutes les aides une nouvelle
branche causée par la premières finisse
par s'éteindre en allemand une itération
sachant que qn moisan et la probabilité
d'extinction ont elles moins une
libération
on a alors qu elle est égale à la
probabilité de zahedan égal zéro qui est
égale l'espérance sur les valeurs de ces
deux adn est égal à zéro sachant a
valeur de 7 ans qui est égal à
l'espérance sur les adhérents de la
probabilité qu'ils les extinctions aide
- une itération puisse en être un en
n'utilisant que adam est égal à x 1
voies que ceux ci l espace sur x2 ql -1
à la puissance x ou x suis ici une loi
binomiale négative cette quantité est
connue sous le nom de fonctions
génératrices des probabilités de x en q1
en 1 ainsi que n est égal à g x2 ql
monza ou gxs est égal à l'espérance de s
puissance x pas récurrence on voit que
cubaine est égal à gérer une fois
appliquée à la valeur de cu 0 qui est
égal à gx itérer une fois appliqué à
zéro puisque qu 0 est la probabilité
d'extinction après 0 itération qui est
égal à zéro voix alors que la suite qu
est née croissante est majoré donc elles
convergent vers un nombre qu qui doit
être solution de l'équation qu est égal
à gx de cul pour résoudre cette équation
j'ai ainsi tracer la courbe y est égal à
g x 2 x et j'ai comparé sa est la droite
y est égal à x sur des semences il pour
une loi binomiale négative de paramètres
air est égal à 3 et cas est égal à 0,1
on trouve de solution de l'équation qui
correspond à qu est égal à 0 84 et puis
été gallach or on peut en fait exclure
qu est égale 1 intuitivement c'est parce
que la pandémie peut exploser
auquel cas son extinction n'arrivera
très probablement pas dès lors la
probabilité qu'une infection de coheed
s'éteignent et qu est égal à 80 4% ce
qui est énorme
voilà qui semblait expliqué comment il
est possible qu'un individu était
infecté en janvier en france sans que
cela ne conduise à une pandémie
en fait plus généralement la probabilité
d'une explosion du coc vie de 6 n
vie du initiaux sont infectés sera un
moins que puissance n
il faut alors n est égal à quatre pour
que cette probabilité dépasse 50% ce qui
signifie qu'un pays doit être effectué
en moyenne autour de 4 fois pour voir
une explosion de son nombre de cas ceci
expliquerait en partie pourquoi la
pandémie a longtemps semblé être sous
contrôle dans de nombreux pays en
février avant de soudainement explosé et
devenir incontrôlable oui car une fois
que cela a explosé alors la valeur
moyenne des aides individuelles des
individus infectés va se rapprocher du r
moyen théorique 6 e r moyen théorique
est supérieur à 1
alors on aura alors une croissance
exponentielle du coc vide
on a vu aujourd'hui que le coc vide
pourrait être associé à une variabilité
individuelle de contagiosité
particulièrement élevé ceci expliquerait
l'étonnante difficulté à identifier et
prédire les foyers de contamination et
l'explosion parfois spectaculaires des
foyers de contamination de façon plus
pragmatique
ceci devrait surtout motivés
l'interdiction des situations propices à
des supers contamination qui semble
particulièrement liées à la
contamination via des gouttelettes
d'individus fortement contaminée qui
respire chante ou respire fortement en
particulier dans des espaces confinés
ceux ci semblent aussi avoir des
conséquences sur la manière optimale
d'effectuer le contact racing pour
identifier davantage de cas à risque
d'infection mais aussi peut-être à
risque d'être de forte contagiosité
néanmoins ceci ne devrait absolument pas
conduire une stigmatisation dangereuse
des supers contaminateur au delà de la
santé vis-à-vis du coc vie de 19
il semble urgent de prendre également
soin de notre santé mentale